hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled accelerating vaccine development
using a next
generation microfluidic ce platform
this webinar is a part of the ongoing
coronavirus virtual webinar series
my name is christy jewell of labyrinths
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
and sponsored by perkin elmer for more
information about perkin elmer
go to perkinelmer.com now let's get
started
i would like to remind everyone that
today's event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type the mini ask a
question box and click send
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
today's presentation click on the ask a
question box
located on the far left of your screen
as a reminder today's presentation is
educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process
to obtain your credits i now present
today's speaker
to ray falwell mid-atlantic and
southeast biotherapeutics solution
specialist at perkin elmer for a
complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
welcome to rae you may now begin your
presentation
hello my name is dre and i'm a
bio-therapeutic solution specialist here
at prick and elmer
today i have the pleasure of talking to
you a little bit about the vaccine
development process
as well as relevant solutions offered by
perkinometer's lab chip gx2 touch ht
when producing a quality vaccine all
manufacturers must confirm the purity as
well the stability of their formulation
and final product
sample quantity and measurement time are
often throughput bottlenecks encountered
during the process
as per knowledge lab chip gx2 test
addresses these specific gaps
and more we've developed a
literature-centric webinar demonstrating
the system's utility
in protein characterization formulation
stability testing and manufacturing
quality control and commercialization
having been employed and bringing nearly
20 drugs to market the system has been
widely adopted throughout the
biopharmaceutical industry
and is often featured as an imperative
process development tool with additional
applications throughout
discovery herein i'll begin by reviewing
the vaccine development process before
delving into relevant applications on a
lab chip gx2 touch
the goal of vaccine process development
is develop a manufacturing process that
can consistently produce a vaccine that
is safe and efficacious
vaccines are biological products that
prevent and control the occurrence of
infectious diseases and epidemic
vaccines and vaccine candidates are
designed to direct against bacteria
viruses fungi parasites and even
non-infectious diseases
the process can be simplified into
pre-clinical development and clinical
development
pre-clinical development is the research
stage carried out in lab assays and on
animals
this includes discovery of relevant
antigens vaccine concept design
evaluation of vaccine efficacy with in
vivo
and and in vitro assays as well as
manufacturing process development of the
vaccine to gmp standards
clinical development is when the vaccine
is first tested in humans and spans four
phases over several years
which we can delve into at a greater
detail
built on rigorous acceptance criteria
clinical development emphasizes vaccine
safety
and efficacy in humans these studies are
completed with informed consent of
volunteers
after animal testing only vaccine
candidates that are considered
safe and induce immunity may advance
through these phases
phase zero though often skipped is an
exploratory phase
where a very small group is treated with
sub-therapeutic amounts of the drug or
vaccine
this is done to determine
pharmacokinetics and the general
metabolic impact
this is roughly 10 people more commonly
a drug or vaccine will begin at
phase one these are small scale trials
that evaluate if the vaccine is safe in
humans and what response it evokes
this involves studies on healthy
volunteers roughly 100 people
with a with the drug being administered
at multiple doses
phase 2 is of a larger scale and
assesses the efficacy of the vaccine
against artificial infection and
clinical disease
this will include testing on actual
patients with therapeutic doses
vaccine safety side effects and the
immune response are all studied
this is about 300 people
phase 3 expands to a larger disease
population of over 1 000 subjects across
several sites to where efficacy under
natural disease conditions is measured
at this point if the product maintains
safety and efficacy over a defined
period
the manufacturer may apply to regulatory
authorities for a license to market the
product for human use
lastly phase 4 assesses the drug or
vaccine use in public this is called
post marketing surveillance and the goal
is to detect
rare adverse effects as well as assess
long-term efficacy
once a product makes it to market
manufacturing must scale accordingly
to meet demand the production of a
vaccine can be further divided into four
steps
propagation and isolation propagation is
amplification of the living organism
used in the vaccine
manufacturers use different methods of
pathogen proliferation according to the
vaccine
to obtain pathogenic protein through dna
this will generate the antigen used in
the immune response
viruses are grown on primary cells such
as chicken embryos
or using fertilized eggs or cell lines
that reproduce repeatedly
bacteria are grown in bioreactors using
a particular growth medium to optimize
antigen production
recombinant proteins derived from the
pathogen therefore can be generated
either in
yeast bacteria or cell cultures
following propagation is isolation of
the antigen
the aim is to release as much virus or
bacteria as possible
to achieve this the antigen is separated
from the cells
and isolated from the proteins and other
parts of the growth medium that are
still present
purification
nitrogen is purified to produce a high
purity and high quality product
all material that may be adhering to the
isolated organism is removed and the
portion of the living organism used in
the vaccine is selectively separated
employing techniques based on the
differences in protein size
physical and chemical properties binding
affinity
and biochemical activity
formulation formulation includes the
antigen of interest in addition
to other components like adjuvants
preservatives
stabilizers all components that
constitute the final vaccine are
combined and mixed uniformly
finally there's packaging the vaccine is
aquatic to sparrow vials
appropriately stored and then shipped
everywhere
the global vaccine market is projected
to reach 58.4 billion usd by 2024
from 41.7 billion usd in 2019
at a compound annual growth rate of 7
during the forecast period
growth of this market has been majorly
attributed to the high prevalence of
infectious diseases
increasing company initiative to enhance
vaccine r d
and growing government support for
vaccine development
however in light of the novel
coronavirus pandemic how might we expect
this forecast to change
the global covet 19 vaccines market
alone is projected to reach
1.4 billion usd by 2025
from 2.27
million usd in 2022 at a compound annual
growth rate
of negative 14.9 percent during the
forecast period
however the capital investments required
for developing vaccines may restrain
market growth
with that said the technology primarily
being used to complete much of the
necessary analysis is antiquated
conventional gel electrophoresis as a
standard for determination of analyte
size
concentration and purity substantially
and
hinders the manufacturing quality
assurance
process labor costs for agarose
gel systems as well as sds paid systems
far exceed those for a capillary
electrophoresis system because the time
required for analysis is much greater
often 101 to 191 minutes
numerous consumables must also be
purchased to use the agarose gel system
although the unit per cost per sample is
only a few dollars
there are about a dozen individual items
to purchase
thus the cost per sample with paige gel
is about three dollars and twelve cents
to five dollars and sixty two cents for
twelve
samples as compared to little as
a dollar fifty per sample when measuring
up to ninety six samples on the
livestream jigs to touch
a process still take roughly an hour
downstream the lab chip is able to
provide substantial value
considering the many challenges in
optimized scale
production purification and quality
assurance are of the most
importance vaccines are biological
products
thus adhere to high regulatory standards
for mitigating the risk to consumer
health
as a quantitative and reproducible tool
is the ideal solution for this process
development
herein i'd like to discuss the laptop
gx2's high throughput capillary
electrophoresis platform
lab2gx2 touch ht is a high throughput
instrument for the
analysis of glycoproteins and nucleic
acids
via microfluidic capillary
electrophoresis in the presence of sps
the system offers an automated
alternative to traditional methods for
streamlining synaptic electrophoresis
while also providing data quality
crucial to modern biotherapeutic
and genomic workflows the system has
four components
our instrument this has a small 20 by 20
inch footprint
and features an easy to use touch screen
integrated with an onboard
windows 10 computer our kit and chip
consumable is used to perform the laser
induced fluorescency technology both are
reusable
and our analysis software providing
electroferogram as well as virtual gel
outputs reporting concentration size and
purity of your analyte
adoption of the platform from r d and
quality control
and manufacturing release is enabled by
an optional 21
cfr 11 compliance package this is ideal
for automatically establishing an audit
trail
with the secure central data repository
and
archive as well as access level
privileges and electronic signature
capabilities
as mentioned the system analyzes nucleic
acid as well as protein and thus is a
powerful analytical tool with many
applications in the vaccine development
and manufacturing space
in the coming slides we'll highlight a
few of what's listed here
a distinguished benefit of the lab chip
platform is that it's extremely easy to
use
this in addition to the measurement
speed make it a very
attractive solution for teams employing
research technicians
acid workflow can be broken down into
simple prep
and chip prep which may be completed in
parallel
for sample prep two microliters of
sample
is added to our sample buffer in a
microchiter plate
followed by heat denaturing during ship
prep a gel dye solution is centrifuged
and then added to the microchip the chip
sample plate and ladder standard can
then be placed on the instrument to
begin measurement
this process takes about 20 minutes
note the dna workflow is very similar
and does not require heat denaturation
protein applications
these days recombinant protein
technologies are being
becoming more important due to their
wide application is biopharmaceutical
products
and proven safety record various
recombinant proteins of
therapeutic and prophylactic importance
have been successfully produced in
microbial and high expression host
systems
most of the vaccines currently being
developed are based on these purified
recommended proteins reaction subunits
recombinant subunit vaccines use
attenuated viruses or bacteria vectors
to introduce microbial dna into cells of
the body
the protein components that induce an
immune response are peptides or antigens
expressed in eukaryotic or prokaryotic
expression systems
expression systems for vaccine
production include prokaryotic
expression systems such as e coli
and eukaryotic systems such as yeast or
mammalian cells or even insect cells
due to the high levels of expression and
ease of handling
bacterial expression systems are the
most widely used system
as an example this is a published study
by vertex from the journal of analytical
biochemistry on the application of a
design of experiment
for antigen expression optimization
utilizing lab chip gx2 technology
the 3d bar chart depicts the results of
the full factorial screening
and clearly identifies the optimal
protein expression condition
each data point was obtained and
measured in triplicate
requiring 288 individual measurements a
largely iterative process that would
take
two weeks using conventional
non-quantitative gel
setup but only an afternoon using the
lab chip
the authors praised the increased
throughput and economies of scale that
now allow for the experiments that were
either prohibitively expensive or too
complex to perform
virus-like particles reveal peas are
non-infectious nanostructures
composed of viral structural proteins
morphologically resembling
authentic variants several vlp-based
vaccine candidates
have been shown to be efficacious in
pre-clinical and clinical trials
some of them have reached the market and
most are targeting non-enveloped viruses
compared to non-envelope vops evops
are much more complex in composition
this example published in
electrophoresis
researchers at the nih's vaccine
research center utilized
black chip gx2 touch in a study for
characterizing venezuelan
equine encephalitis or vee
virus select particles this is a vlp
featuring the complex
lipid and envelope moiety
the top figure is an electric fairground
profile overlay depicting the particle
separation
observed in all three stereotypes the
axes correspond to size in kilodalton
versus relative fluorescent units
the area under the curve corresponds to
the percent amount of particle component
within the total sample
the bottom graph is a representative
calibration curve for vee
with axes corresponding to vlp
concentration in microgram per
milliliter
versus area response these authors
command the method sensitivity for
analyzing low concentration vaccine
candidates
both in process development samples and
the final drug
note the standard method for envelope
virus like particle quantitation
requires additional preparation and may
lengthen
the analysis by up to three times
closing this section out i'd like to
talk a little bit
about aavs as this technology also
exhibits promising potential in the
vaccine space
on the left is a six is a six human
infecting viruses
that appear somewhat similar from bottom
left clock balls
we have influenza virus neurovirus
oxy virus enterovirus d68
poliovirus and finally adeno-associated
virus which we're highlighting in the
right image
adeno-associated virus is a small
non-pathogenic virus consisting
of a protein shell which encapsulates a
4.7 kilobase genome
originally cited in 1965 as replication
defective
contaminated of adenovirus stock today
aavs have the magnificent purpose of
serving as vehicles for gene delivery
gene therapy vectors using aav can
infect
both dividing and quiescent cells with
several serotypes demonstrating
preferences for different tissue the rep
gene encodes four proteins required for
genome replication and packaging the cap
gene
produces three of our proteins vp1 vp2
and vp3 which forms a protective outer
shell
and aids in hostile binding
the lab trips microfluidic ces has
already been proven to
be a welcome alternative for quantifying
capsid proteins vp1 vp2 vp3
and contaminating proteins and aavs as
compared to the qualitative
interpretation of sds page with silver
staining
where reproducibility is a challenge and
dentatometry can
be manipulated note this is only
one of the many solutions for av
characterization offered on the lab chip
for years per knowledge microfluidic ce
has been adopted in the monoclonal
antibody industry
as a quantitative and reproducible
analysis approach with excellent
sensitivity
and speed yielding digital records in
the gmp environment
as the production of drugs and vaccines
is achieved from the propagation of
living organisms
some of which may be dangerous human
pathogens
it is not only pertinent that
manufacturing is conducted
in a highly regulated and controlled
environment but also that we can
maintain confidence in the final product
with that said the lab ship has been
used widely throughout the biopharma not
only to ensure the identity
strength and quality of drug substances
but also to screen the performance of
pharmaceutical
excipients and monitor the chemical and
physical stability
of the antigen within these complex
matrices
nucleic acid applications
as the lab tip is an extremely versatile
system
it can also be used to analyze nucleic
acids
in applications related to recombinant
vaccine development
is crucial to screen the plasmid library
preceding introduction into a host cell
the length and quality of the
recombinant dna components must be
confirmed
compared to the conventional across
shells
the lab chip provides greater
sensitivity and higher resolution
here we compare three commercial ladder
standards measured on a two percent
agarose gel
and on the lap chip with roughly 60
seconds for measurement
this is completed in less than three
minutes using our dna 5k assay
compared to the 30 minutes needed to
achieve separation on this two percent
and betraying egypt note that egel does
not resolve the triplet
of 4 13 417 and 427 base period
fragments
or any fragments above 3 000 base pair
this is a critical bottleneck within a
technology for quality checking plasmid
fragments
as a result can be an ineffective batch
given the sensitivity and resolution of
the lab chip it only
not only resolves seized rapidly but can
handle much larger illegal nuclear touch
the same system can similarly be used
for rna analysis
demonstrated on this slide is mrna
expression data
generated on the lab chip sensitivity
and resolution featured in
other assays is mirrored here with the
added benefit
of a calculated rna quality score or rqs
determined by the degree of sample
degradation
holding to our vaccine development
regime we'll close
by speaking briefly about rna vaccines
rna vaccines are novel as they do not
stimulate
and prime the body's immune response
these vaccines work by introducing
an mrna sequence which is coded for
a disease-specific antigen the quality
assurance metrics for these
constructs may be confirmed on a lab
chip and are extremely important for
vaccine efficacy
once produced within the body the
antigens recognize itself
by the immune system and is therefore
prepared to
combat the real thing
wrapping up the lab chip gx2 touch hd is
a high-throughput instrument the
analysis of glycoproteins and nucleic
acids via microfluidic capillary
electrophoresis
in the presence of sds adoption of the
platform from r d and the quality
control and manufacturing release
is enabled by an optional 21 cfr 11
compliance package
when producing a quality vaccine all
manufacturers must comply with gmp
regulations
as well as maintain confidence in their
product
perkin elmer's lab chip gh2 touch offers
a quantitative and reproducible platform
for not only confirming the purity
and stability of the final product but
also means for providing a variety of
additional analyses from protein
expression and characterization
to even glycan analysis and charged
heterogeneity
as a multi-faceted instrument it would
be a welcome addition to
almost any laboratory settings
especially that of a vaccine development
center
with that said thank you very much for
your time i'd like to conclude by citing
the excellent literature and image
sources featured during this talk
for questions on the concept of this
presentation as well as additional
information on broken element solutions
for automation and microfluidics
please refer to my contact information
displayed here
it was a pleasure preparing this for you
and we look forward to hearing from you
soon
have a wonderful day stay healthy
happy and inquisitive
thank you to rae for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a
portion of our webinar now to our
audience if you have a question you
would like to ask
please do so now just click on that ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started jaray let's start
with this question
aside from protein sizing and
purity what other assays are available
and that's a great question so it's a
very versatile instrument
in addition to protein it can do dna and
rna
but uh still in the protein space i'd
like to highlight that it has the
capability of analyzing
n-linked glycans and could also do
charge variance if you're
interested in seeing the acidic and
basic moies of your protein
so it's uh it's pretty versatile what
you can do
great question thank you
and how fast can a lab chip analyze my
protein sample
so it's a very high throughput
instrument it's actually able to do
protein samples in about 42 seconds per
sample
and that's for our base assay we have
assays that
go up to 62 seconds but
it's uh when you compare it to doing a
page shell that could take you a couple
hours for about 12 samples it's uh
it's a pretty good on the speed front
i'd say
42 seconds is the answer
thank you our next question
i have limited samples how can the lab
chip
help me
and that's another good question so it's
a microfluidic ce system
so the sample input is minimum when
you're actually
preparing for the protein assay you only
need two microliters of sample
and that will go through our workflow
when the
zipper on the chip actually injects it
into the system
it actually only sips nanoliters
so it actually preserves a lot of your
samples so you're able to
kind of freeze the plates and reuse them
afterwards if you like
very good and jerry we have time for one
more question
what's the sizing range for biologics on
the lab chip
and that's uh so it's a good question
because we recently
released a new assay so we're actually
able to size from six kilo dollars up to
250 kilograms
so it's a pretty broad range for what
we're able to analyze on that machine
thank you jaray now do you have any
final comments for our audience i'd say
it was a
fantastic time preparing this for you
all and
i recommend that you check out the
perkin hour booth
download some literature watch our
videos and chat with the representatives
to see what solutions we have within the
portfolio
that could help you accelerate your
research
thank you so much for your time
listening and thank you so much for your
help christina
and thank you jaray for your time today
and your important research
now before we go i do want to thank our
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions we
have quite a few questions we were
unable to answer so i want to remind
our audience that those questions we
were unable to answer and additionally
those that come in during the on-demand
period they will be addressed by our
speaker via the contact information you
provided
at the time of registration one final
thank you to
our sponsor perkin elmer
now today's webcast can be viewed on
demand through this
through the end of this year 2020 lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
and we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
thanks for joining us we hope to see you
again soon
have a great day